the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I've mentioned randomized linear
algebra a few times and I thought ok I'm
gonna jump in and describe randomized
matrix multiplication it's a pretty cool
idea it seems to me so so this is a
topic within randomized linear algebra
and when would we be doing any of this
it would be for matrices that are just
really really large so we plan to sample
the columns of a and sample the
corresponding rows of B so actually the
when we decide on a column we've also
decided on a row so we're taking those
pieces which do correctly add up to a B
but we're not going to take them all
we're going to take different ones
randomly sampled with probabilities we
have to decide probabilities and then
we'll add up our samples and we hope
that the result is close to a B that's
the idea okay so this this lecture then
so I wrote these pages about six months
ago so I've been desperately trying to
remember what I wrote because it's not a
subject I have ever spoken about before
but it's so neat so here are some of the
things that come into it we have to
decide on probabilities then we want to
compute the mean so so it's it's our
first day with some of these key I
from statistics and probability so we're
gonna take probabilities that add to one
we're gonna figure out what's the mean
value of our random a B we hope and we
will see that the mean value of the
random a B is the correct a B but there
will be a variance we won't get every
sample won't be correct in fact no
samples will be correct
only when we add them up on the average
the correct answer we get to correct a B
but so the mean will come out right
it'll come out as a B you'll see it
happen
correct but there's a big variance not
zero will be all over the place
with our samples they'll just average
out right but they'll be all over
no no particular sample will be right at
all so then we want to pick the best
probabilities when the so our job will
be once we see how the system works
we're going to assign probabilities and
we're going to choose the probabilities
that minimize the variance so this is a
typical situation where the mean is
pretty straightforward and and does what
you want but having the correct mean
does not mean you've got good answers at
all the average of you know like minus M
minus a hundred and a hundred is it
might be a correct answer is zero but
you're way off so and this measures how
far you are so I don't know if you know
these words it's unfortunate but I guess
1806 five can't change it now that the
variance is written Sigma squared and we
already have a good use for the letter
the Greek letter Sigma but
today it has a different use for
variance and this lagron suppliers will
come in near the end so basically let me
let me do a practice example to kind of
recall what mean and variance and what
those are about so let me take a matrix
that's 1 by 2 so my my matrix is just
gonna be a B okay I'm gonna sample that
and twice and my rule for the two
samples will be the same they will be
identically distributed totally
identical and what's my rule gonna be so
this is like practice my rule is going
to be I take that column or that column
with probabilities 1/2 okay and I do it
twice so so and I take the average so
I'm going to take probabilities they're
going to be one half one half for the
two columns and I'm gonna do s equal to
two samples and I'm gonna add weight
them with and I'll take the average of
the two samples okay and that will be my
randomized matrix okay so could we
compute the mean for this so I've
described a randomized sampling process
I've given you the probabilities half
and a half the number of times I'm going
to do it and then I divide by that
number of times so this is really I have
a 1 over s here because I've got s of
these and now so what are the
possibilities here I want to find the
mean first of all it's
was a mean okay so here are two I could
think of two different ways to compute
the mean let me start with this one what
is the mean the average value mean means
average value of the first sample so the
average value of the first sample I
would what does the mean the general
formula is you add up all the sample
sample times it's the possible samples
times their probabilities and in this
case the probabilities are one-half that
the sample is a zero and one half that
the sample is zero beat so those are my
two samples and computing the mean of
the total I get oh but that mean for
each sample but then I have to multiply
so so let's put what I got here half of
a be that was the meaning of each sample
because my probabilities were equal half
and half and now I've got se for two
samples so I multiply by 2 and I get a B
and the mean mean is correct
good we did the easy one the mean now
practice with the variance or else quit
here maybe I should quit while I'm ahead
I've got the mean exactly right but of
course the samples might not be right so
what's so now for the variance so how do
what is variance do you remember that
there are actually two ways to compute
variance
let me just remember those over here and
push that board up so the variance Sigma
squared forgive me if you're a
statistician this is like like you know
Brent like you were born knowing this
but the rest of us were not so the
variance is there's the sum one way to
do it is add up the different
probabilities of different things that
could happen of output minus the mean
squared so it's the average it's the
average distance squared from the meat
so it takes whatever output I have that
came with output number I minus the mean
which is the average output I square
those and I get a number and that sort
of tells me how that tells me like in
the in the famous Gaussian
if I had a Gaussian distribution here I
have a distribution of 1/2 and 1/2 so
I'm like that's maybe even has a name
like binomial or something or Bernoulli
or whatever but here on this Gaussian
that we all remember
can I mark in the what in that figure
where the mean is that right in the
center like ok me and can and what is
the variance just to recall what
everybody in the first time may even
hear that word variance the what is the
variance kind of measuring it's it's
your you're summing squares so whether
you're on the right of the mean or the
left of the mean no difference because
you're squaring it and it's the distance
so so the mean the variance would be
sort of like a typical width maybe I
overdid it but that would be a sort of
typical Sigma I'm really just since the
words statistics mean and variance
haven't been mentioned in 1806 five
until today I'm just kind of recalling
them ok so now I'm prepared to compute
this example ok maybe I'll maybe I'll
compute it over here ok so so I compute
the variance for each sample and then
I'll multiply by two because I have two
samples so what are they so this is the
Sigma squared sample obviously I could
write down all the possibilities yeah
let me just do this a month so the
sample could either have picked out a 0
or 0 B and the probabilities were 1/2 so
I I have 1/2 times the probability times
the output let's say the output is
a zero minus the mean which was a over
to be over two and I want to square that
so that was one possibility when I
picked a zero and the other one which
I'm also doing with probability 1/2 is
in case I picked 0 B what was you see
I'm I'm not getting 0 for the variance
because every time I'm making an error
every time I'm never getting the correct
a zero or the correct zero B because I'm
always doing this one in the middle okay
now if I compute all that I get a
quantity and maybe I'll just be to be on
the safe side
ask your forgiveness if I write the
answer and we could even try to get the
answer but so this is from two samples
so this is doubled that one do
I guess I'm bold enough to try it so so
a zero so that would be a minus a over
two and a B and a B over two I think
we've got here one half of I think looks
to me like a over two squared plus B
over I'm missing by plus or minus but it
when I'm squaring them that's the whole
point of variance doesn't matter and the
B over two and here I think I'm I'm
wrong by a over two and I'm wrong by
plus by B over
two or minus eight over two but when I
square them again doesn't matter so I
think I get another half of a over two
squares plus B over 2 squared
what forgive me for this simple
computation but just to practice so what
have I got I've got a half of that in
half of that so that adds up to this
thing a squared over four plus B squared
over four but then I'm doing two samples
I'll have to multiply by the number of
samples so I think so times two for two
samples I think I'm getting it was 1/4
but now it'll be 1/2 of a squared B
Square oh yeah I didn't yeah yeah hey
yeah I think I think that's right but
forgive me while I just ask myself yeah
yeah this will be actually you already
have these notes
this is section 2.4 so it's I think it's
their own stiller so what's the point of
this first point was to like remember
some of the steps that go into the
variance oh there's another formula for
variance that I want to tell you and the
second point is to make to bring in a
new idea suppose we want to make this
suppose this variance is bigger than we
want suppose for example that B is a lot
bigger than a suppose B is a lot bigger
than a then what should we have done
differently in this random randomized
linear algebra if I'm trying to get this
thing closed get close to that thing and
if B is a lot bigger than a then what
should I do different
I don't know what B is exactly but I
have the information that it's bigger
than a then I should increase the
probability I shouldn't do half and half
so here here was randomized sampling
taking the average my probabilities were
a half and a half but if I want I
believe that I could keep the mean
correct of course that's fundamental to
get the mean right and get a better
answer get a smaller variance than that
B squared over there by picking that
thing with higher probability so that's
where the randomized 'men out to be
called norm squared probability the I
the the decision on what the probability
should be goes it turns out to be the
optimal one goes with the square of the
size so if B is twice as big as a and I
want to get the variance down then the
probability I should use probabilities
that are four times four times as often
I will choose B than a that's going to
be the conclusion at two o'clock
hopefully okay there so that's one point
and and just another little point while
we're while we are reviewing variance
this is the standard formula for the
variance sum of all the possible
outcomes with their probabilities the
distance from the mean squared do you
know a second formula which is very
close to this and very similar and it
comes from substituting the meaning of
means something where the mean is so
yeah so I just I just want to mention a
second formula and I don't I don't know
which one will actually use but the
second formula for the same quantity
Sigma square is this sum of
probabilities times output square so I
haven't subtracted off the mean in this
second formula I have to do it now and
I'll do the mean I'll do the mean all at
once mean squared of course the mean
involves remember that the mean is the
sums of the probabilities times the
outcomes and it's just playing with a
little algebra to show that you can
either you have a choice of whatever is
more convenient subtract the mean off
from each output or do all the outputs
but then you haven't accounted for the
fact that you really want the distances
from the mean and then you subtract off
the mean squared two ways to do it
two ways to equal ways to do it yeah we
will review the basic ideas of mean and
variance in the in the in the section on
probability here I'm yes question yeah
the mean oh in in here
at separate yeah that's the whole point
yeah so this was like do this and then
subtract off the mean squared or keep
the mean in every term and do it that
way
you could verify that the two are are
the same okay so when we go now to the
bigger question I've forgotten which way
I do it but I'm free to choose okay is
that like a small sample reasonable and
you and you get the idea that if if we
know that if we if we look at our matrix
first of all and find out which columns
are large dot large norm and which
columns are smaller then that might be
useful information to weight our
probabilities to pick the larger one
more often okay okay well in fact let me
just tell you what are the two
possibilities there one is what I just
said wait your probabilities by the
square of the norm this norm squared
waiting that we'll see and take the
columns as they come but with higher
probability on the big columns or you
could say another way would be mix the
columns so that they more or less have
similar sizes and then keep track of
what you've done and then and then just
the probabilities can all be equal so
that would be the other way take your
matrix mix it up take combinations of
the columns with random numbers there's
a random world here take you do a mixing
and then operate on the mixed matrix
yeah okay I'm going to do it the first
way I'm gonna pick these probabilities
to there'll be they'll turn out to be
proportional to norm squared okay ready
for that here it comes
so bring that down yeah okay actually I
could leave it up for now cuz it told us
what we're what we're up to
okay so so what have I got
let me just see if I can so so we're
multiplying a times B and we're gonna
use these probabilities PJ is going to
be the length of that column times the
length of that row norm squared well
norm squared if I was multiplying a by a
transpose then I really would be
squaring that would be the same as that
so I'm gonna use the word norm squared
or length squared also here where the
two I'm not assuming that B is a
transpose okay
so that will be the probabilities will
be proportional to that but now those
that don't add up to one so how do I
make the probabilities add up to one
this is the probability of of choosing
column J of a x times row J that's what
that's what PJ refers to okay
okay so what is my plan oh I have to
make the probabilities add to one or I'm
really breaking them the fundamental law
here so how if I have a bunch of
probabilities and I kind of know what I
want but they don't add up to one what
do i do / their sum let me call see
there's some so the probability is going
to be that over C and C is is going to
be the sum of however many rows and
columns I guess maybe I had R and my
picture of a J VJ transpose okay so all
I did was rescale the probabilities so
that they now add to one good okay so
now I'm ready to go to work I'm ready to
choose oh yes so here's my rule I will
choose row column and column row J with
this probability but then I'm going to
multiply it and I'm free to do that if I
want to so my approximation my
approximate ami will be I'll take this
whichever comes out I'll take the AJ be
j transpose there comes out it comes out
with probability P J but I'm going to
divide this by and I think I'm this is
the right one s the number of samples
times PJ so I thought at first that's
weird
went to all the trouble to pick these P
J's claiming that these are the good
ones so I'm my claim to eventually prove
at the end first I'll have to understand
how the sampling is done that's like the
most important but then when I go
to compute the mean I'll get the correct
mean and when I go to get to compute the
variance I'll get some expression for
the variance and then the plan will be
choose these PJ's to minimize that total
variance so here so this is what that's
a that's a typical sample with
probability PJ pick that that matrix
that rank one matrix so then my
approximate a B is the sum of all these
over s samples are you with me let me
let me just repeat I'm trying to
multiply a B each sample is just a
single column times row so it's way
wrong way wrong it's just a tiny piece
of a B but I take that sample with
probability PJ and I divide it by s PJ
so that's a PJ's cancel here oh yes okay
right so I would like to see that the
mean is correct I would like to see that
the mean is correct I'm going to compute
the mean of my process so it's like it's
falling into my lap here I made it that
way
these PJ's canceled I divided by s so
the mean of a typical sample will be so
the mean of one sample is the
probability of getting it times what I
take so it's just the sum of a jb j
transpose / s you're going to say okay
you're wasting our time but we've got a
I would just want to show that I'm
getting the correct mean
out of this plan so do you see that if
that's a mean of one sample so what's
the mean of the sum of all the samples
well x yes because it was the same mean
every sample that the same mean just
just as it did in our little league
practice example so that's the mean of
one sample so the mean of all samples
added added together multiplies this by
s yeses cancel and I get a B remembering
my however way I defined a B there yeah
all I'm saying there here is that I did
something reasonable in the sampling
process so that the mean came out right
and now is the hard part
the variance what's the variance okay so
what do I have to compute and I may it
will depend on the piece P 1 to P R I
guess we had we had our different rows
different column row pairs to choose and
we chose probabilities these guys that
depended on the size and now I'm going
to compute the variance and it won't be
0 because every sample is wrong I'm
never getting from a sample a sample is
just giving me a wrote a column times a
row a rank one guy
and they averaged out to give the
correct product but each one is
certainly wrong because it's just a rank
one so when I compute variance I'm going
to definitely not get zero right in
other words of course when were the
variance be zero yeah if a B were ranked
one I guess I'd get it right every time
thanks oh there's a better answer than I
had in mind yeah yeah the variance would
only be zero if every sample was right
and that would be true if the rank was
one and there was only one thing to
choose but that's not the problem we
want okay so the variance is there my my
instinct is to tell you what this
calculation produces since you and I can
read would you allow me to do that so
here the variance for a sample turns out
to be it turns out to equal so we will
figure it out
turns out to equal the sum over as it
was up there of the AJ AJ transpose
probably squared let me just just check
yes squared yeah why don't I help myself
here so these are squared because
variances are squared and then when I
look to see what I think there's an S
there and there's a PJ so why is there a
PJ there when it cancelled here so here
the PJ when I multiplied by that
cancelled why doesn't it cancel over
there because it's squared over there
over there this thing is squared so it
was PJ twice here
PJ it's probability once so I'm still we
got the PJ in the denominator 1 factor
of PJ in the denominator and then so
that is I guess what I'm doing is I'm
computing the variance this way so what
I've computer now is his first bit and
then I said should should subtract the
mean squared and this is for one sample
so the mean squared is I think it turns
out to be 1 over s times C times a B
squared in this Frobenius norm it's it's
the a squared plus B squared stuff that
I saw before so okay so this I've jumped
a serious step to get from the sum
formula for the variance I've plugged in
this problem and got that okay and now
I'm gonna sample let's see where it yeah
oh I want I would like to simplify this
I would like to simplify that so I have
to plug in the PJs okay so I have to
plug in for that PJ and we decided what
PJ was going to be
here okay so when I plug that in in the
denominator it will cancel one of these
and I'll just have a sum of a JPG of a
JP j bj norms and what's that is C so
let me say this again just it's
something you can just check when you
have a minute when I plug in that value
for PJ here it cancels the squares and
just leaves the first power so then I'm
adding up the first power and I get C
and but the PJ had a factor C in the
denominator and it's in the denominator
over there so that C is up there so it's
C squared coming here a constant square
minus the other term there's a 1 over s
that will eventually go away and this
other term is 1 over s more maybe the
Frobenius norm squared well maybe one
over SS are so you're seeing and I
apologize
a little bit messy bit of algebra a
little bit messy bit of algebra but
that's what we that's what we ended up
with and when we take s samples and
combine them that will cancel the s and
the I think it'll knock that out when we
combine the s samples okay yeah okay
know what now we get to choose those
probabilities and how are we gonna
choose them what will be the best choice
here's the expression for the variance
yeah this is good this is good
stay with me from now on you you you
you'll be saying to yourself there's
some steps there that I didn't see fully
and I want to check but and I agree but
let me say that we get to that point and
this is a fixed number so it's C that we
would like to make small and that's our
final job this was true for any choice
of the probabilities P well oh yeah yep
yep so I want to the this still had in
it the probabilities yeah where do I
want to do I want to show that those
that was the best choice that this was
the best choice yeah I want to show that
that's the best choice that's a choice
of weights of probabilities based on the
length of a time's the length of B of
course that sounds reasonable doesn't it
we want to four big big columns and big
rows we want to have a higher
probability to choose those but is the
probability proportional to the length
of both or should it be proportional to
the 10th power or the square root or
what that's what our final step of
optimizing the P so this is the final
step
optimize the probabilities P 1 to P s I
guess no P 1 to P R for the R rows or
columns of a and our rows of B subject
to their you have to add up to 1 and
what do I mean by optimize I mean
minimize this is optimize means
minimizing this expression C so AJ BJ
transfer where's it's the over PG o hope
help help
so let me just see ya my variance has
got a PJ in it yeah my variance sorry my
variance oh okay this is my variance
this is the result if I make the right
choice for the if I make this choice for
the probabilities but I'm backing up a
minute this is if this is the with
optimal
PJ's then we got that answer great that
was our answer
but I'm backing up to this and saying
what are the optimal PJs for to make
this variance small so I'm I'm really
I'm just doing what doing this I let me
right there the problem simpler minimize
with the some of the peas equal one some
quantity q squared over QJ / PJ yeah
that's it how do you so these q JS that
i just introduced that letter for are
the AJ B J's they're they're given maybe
I'll just put put back AJ PJ so to
repeat this is the calculation of the
variance for any choice of PJs this is
what I get if I make the best choice but
over here I'm gonna show that it is the
best choice because that it's the choice
that makes this result as small as
possible so that's the the groans Mulder
plier aspect so we there statistics has
been done I'm get I'm getting this
answer and instead of putting in some
weird Q let me put in what these are
they're whatever they're bunch of
numbers but I'm dividing by the PJ and
how do you find the best PJ do you know
about that optimization question I they
have to add to one and the Grouch had
the great idea so this is maybe the
first time we've used his idea so do you
remember what his idea
he takes this constraint and he builds
it into the function he multiplies it by
some unknown mysterious number often
called lambda but nothing to do with
eigenvalues of the concern of the
constraints that the PI's should add to
one so he had zero he had zero but with
a variable lambda this is Lagrange's
idea so it's it's pretty neat that this
problem I've left randomized sampling
I've arrived at this final subproblem
optimizing the probabilities under the
condition that they add to one and
Lagrange's idea was build that equation
into the function then you can take
derivatives but you also take
derivatives with respect to lambda
because that's now an unknown and you
solve you set the derivatives to zero
and you get the answer it's like a
miracle but if you've seen the ground
it's a confusing miracle that's what it
is yeah okay so if I take the
derivatives of the spec to the peas set
them to zero I think I'm going to get
the recommended Peas so that so I've
I've computed the final answer with a
recommended piece but now I'm going to
show that they really are recommended so
can you take the derivative of that with
respect to P could I just raise this a
little raise it a little more okay take
the derivative with respect to P each P
because I've got n unknowns there are
however many maybe are unknowns and I've
got lambda so I've got R plus 1 things
so what's the derivative this break to P
okay calculus take the derivative that
it's a J VJ transpose over with a minus
P J squared right
and the derivative of that with respect
to PJ is minus lambda so that's
derivative the specter PJ is 0 and the
derivative so this was the derivative
with respect to PJ has to be 0 and then
the derivative respect to lambda into
respect to lambda is that JS JS minus
equals 1 the lagravis confused the whole
world but he gave us a break that in the
derivative the specter lambda it just
brings back the constraint because he
just built it in with a factor lambda
then he took the derivative and it
brought back the constraint but this
part is the beautiful part now what do I
learn from that and sometimes sometimes
this would be a plus why don't I make it
a plus just to make my life easier
LeBron said it's dead now and he don't
care anyway whether it's closer on - ok
ok so so this is telling me this so this
is telling me what what hits multiplier
is he's telling me that if this equation
is telling me that the multiplier is AJ
VJ transpose / PJ squared or put another
way he's telling me that PJ squared is I
guess I'm hoping that after the pretty
confusing steps that we took this is a
separate a little bit of math using the
LaGrant apply or an idea and I hope that
your your result your thought will be
boy that was pretty simple so I'm gonna
put the PJ Squared's here in the lane
okay well what does this tell me look
I've taken the derivative the spec to
the PJs and I got this equation for each
J but I took the derivative the partial
derivatives back to each of the PJs and
it tells me that PJ squared wait a
minute what's the square and therefore
help I've only got two minutes and oh
they have to add to one oh yeah lambdas
gonna save us haha right
lambda is gonna save us because the
total probabilities so PJ will be the
square root of this stuff and then I the
number lambda I haven't decided
Lagrange's multiplier haven't decided so
what is it it's the correct number to
make this equal to one so that's that is
the C oh god what have I got square root
there shoot I should have started with
squares so these should be squares ah
thank you
you could have told me earlier use when
you see a professor in trouble don't
let's just let him hang there okay right
okay and this is AJ BJ so apart from the
kerfuffle here and the notes get it
right because I had time to think there
that it it turns out that
this optimum gave the formula for the
PJs that I used earlier so when I
introduced this formula I said let's
take let's choose those probabilities
but then I came back at the very end and
showed that they are the probabilities
that minimize the variance so that's
like today's lecture can you just think
a minute but please do go back through
the notes because there's some messy
steps in the variance there that I had
to go by quickly but you understand the
principle that we set up a randomized
system we we choose probabilities aiming
to get the the best the smallest
variance and it turns out that the good
probabilities are bigger when the column
is a big a larger column so that to use
this you have to go through the matrix
and find the lengths of the columns
because that's what's telling you the
probabilities so that's a like a first
pass through before you do the
randomized sampling you must decide on
the probabilities and they depend on the
sizes of the different columns thank you
for getting me through that I'll come
back to a little more about randomized
things next time and then later not much
later but a little bit later we'll be
seeing probability much more seriously
okay thank you